so we're told that ae is equal to 12
that's this side right over here and ec
is equal to 18. ec is equal to 18 and
then they've drawn a bunch of the
medians here for so we know that they
are medians because when they intersect
the opposite side they're telling us
that this length is equal to this length
or that e d is equal to dc
cb is equal to ba af is equal to fe or
that f b and d are the midpoints and the
g then would be the centroid where the
medians intersect and so the first thing
they ask us is what is the area of bgc
so bgc right here that is
this triangle right over there and to
figure that area we just have to remind
ourselves that the three medians of a
triangle divide a triangle to divide a
triangle into six
six triangles that have equal area so if
we know the area of the entire triangle
and i think we can figure this out this
is a right triangle they're telling us
that ae this entire distance right over
here is going to be 12.
so this is going to be 12. let me show
you enough space this entire distance
right over here is 18. they tell us that
so the area
the area of aec
a
ec
is going to be equal to one-half times
the base which is 18 times the height
which is 12 which is equal to 9 times 12
which is 108. that's the area of this
entire right triangle triangle aec if we
want the area of bgc
or any of these smaller of the six
triangles i if we ignore this little
altitude right over here the ones that
are bounded by the medians then we just
have to divide this by six because they
all have equal area we've proven that in
a previous video so the area of b
g c
is equal to the area of a ec the entire
triangle divided by 6 which is 108
divided by 6 which is what it's 60 let's
see you get 10 and then 48 looks like it
would be 18. it would be 18. and that's
right because it would be this is a 108
is the same thing as 18 times 6. so we
did our first part the area of that
right over there is 18. and if we wanted
we could say the area of any of these
triangles these the ones that are
bounded by the medians this is going to
be 18 this is going to be 18. this
entire fge triangle is going to be 18
but we did this first part right over
there
now they ask us
what is the length of a g so a g
is the distance it's the longer part of
this median right over here and to
figure out what a g is we just have to
remind ourselves that the centroid the
centroid is always two-thirds along the
way of the medians or divides the
mediant into two segments that have a
ratio of two to one so if we know the
entire length of this median we could
just take two-thirds of that and that
will give us the length of a g and lucky
for us this is a right triangle
and we know that we know that f and d
are the midpoints so for example we know
that this ae is 12 that was given we
know that e d is half of this 18
so e d right over here i'll do this in a
new color
e d is going to be nine
e d is going to be nine so then we can
just use the pythagorean theorem to
figure out what a d is a d is the
hypotenuse of a of this right triangle a
ad so we're looking at triangle aed
right now so we know that
let me write this down we know that 12
squared
12 squared plus 9 squared
plus 9 squared is going to be equal to a
d squared
is going to be equal to
a d
a d squared 12 squared is 144
144 plus 81
plus
plus 81 and so this is going to be equal
to ad squared so this is what this is
225 so we have 225
is equal to ad squared
is equal to ad squared and 225 you may
or may not recognize is 15 squared so a
d
a d is equal to 15. you want to take the
principal root the positive root because
we're talking about distances or lengths
of sides we don't care about the
negatives so 80 is equal to 15. so this
whole thing right over here is going to
be equal to 15
and a g is going to be two thirds of a d
a g is equal to two thirds of a d we
proved that in a previous video that the
centroid is two-thirds along the way of
any of these medians and we can do it
for any of the medians so it's equal to
two-thirds
times fifteen which is equal to
which is equal to ten so a g right over
here
a ag right over here is equal to
is equal to 10. so we did the second
part now this third part what is the
area of f
of f
g
h so let me let me color it in
f
g h
so if we knew this length if we knew h g
and if we knew fh we could easily figure
out what that area is and there's
actually multiple ways of figuring out
either one of those things so one way
one way that we can think about finding
what h g is is to remind ourselves is to
remind ourselves that hg
is the altitude of either triangle f g e
or triangle a f g and both of them have
a base of six
both of them have a base of six so this
is six and this is six over here and
then they have a height equal to gh and
we know what their area is we know that
the area is already equal to 18. so you
can say so let's take this triangle up
here
so when we're talking about the area
area of triangle a f g so we know it's
one half
times its base which is six
times its height which is gh
times gh that's just one half base times
height is equal to the area of this
triangle which is going to be equal to
18.
and so then we just have to tell
ourselves well this is 3 times gh is
equal to 18
gh
if we divide both sides of this by if we
divide both sides of this by 3 gh is
equal to six so that is one way to do it
gh is equal to six you could have also
made a similarity argument that you
could said look this is this triangle up
here is similar to this larger triangle
over here this is this this hypotenuse
is two-thirds of the length of this
entire thing so this is going to be
two-thirds of this nine so that's
another way that you could have gotten
six there but either way we got this
length
now we just have to figure out what fh
is and we can figure out what fh is
if we know what a h is
if we know what a h is because we know a
to f is 6 so fh is going to be ah
minus af so let's figure out what a h is
well once again we can make a similarity
argument and if we want to do it
formally we see both of the the larger
this this larger right triangle and the
smaller right triangle both have a 90
degree angle there they both have this
angle in common so they have two angles
in common they are definitely similar
triangles
and so we know the ratio of ah
let me write down orange we know that
the ratio of ah
to a e which is 12
is equal to the ratio of a g
which is 10
10 to the ratio of a d which we already
figured out was 15.
so one way to think about it is a h is
going to be two-thirds of 12 well we can
just work through the math just using
the similar triangles so this right-hand
side right over here is just two over
three and so a h multiplying both sides
by 12 is equal to two-thirds times 12
which is just if you do is just h so a h
here is eight
a h is eight a f is six
so
f h right over here f h right over here
is going to be 2. and so now we have
enough information to figure out the
area of fhg it's going to be one-half so
let me write it over here it's going to
be
one-half times the base i'll just use fh
as the base here although i could just
do it either way i can use well i'll
just fh as the base one-half times two
times the height times six which is
equal to six
and we are done
and you could keep going you could
figure out the length of pretty much all
of these segments here using some of
these techniques or any of these areas
which we've actually figured out most of
them